[Music]
in lieu some winsome news you submitted
by piece set sounds like a like a gang
like he's that like URI dad set SCT
okay that's one clever that help you it
helps me write you an image to go along
with this an extrapolate manager who was
accused of stealing $626 now gets an
eight million dollar settlement
defamation yes defamation
okay couldn't get a job why are you
laughing Steve
cuz it's [ __ ] access guitar and the
face pushing yeah those two things it
reached the infantile child apartment do
you want a kid honey you do want one
yeah yeah you let it out that jar why
does he say he doesn't well he goes back
and forth I want a lot of kids I did
that people can help me take becoming
here excuse me maybe I'm like no no see
that's the thing is I want a kid by
don't with the baby yeah I want to just
be for that's for yeah I want the baby I
just don't want to take you there pretty
cool I didn't know the first three
months though I can skip I really give a
[ __ ] about that no I'm alright
wall Arnaz [ __ ] lay right there staring
out the sky yeah you can't be running
around chasing a baby when our vaginas
turning yeah stupid needs that time I
chase after having to have a good time
what do they do in these like tribal
situations when you pop out kids because
you see like you know them sharing that
work and then you don't see the guys
doing any other [ __ ] baby work well
they're hunting [ __ ] this is real
question is how can I get in the
scenario where guys are not to do any
[ __ ]
no bears and bison and all the [ __ ] you
got it I would love to do that you guys
because I'm meant to Africa when I pop
out kids will go on hunting trips and
Wyoming we [ __ ] shoot these reds and
gathered ya can't take a bear you
kidding me G oh you don't think I could
take a bear are you serious right have
you thought how [ __ ] soft your hands
are very soft
wait what about to pull they dude what
about it Nikki I we didn't even hear the
story you don't call me a [ __ ] I can't
let that I didn't call you a [ __ ] I
said you have soft hands yeah true
that's me you just want to feel him real
bad don't you no no you do you want to
feel real real bad oh I can back stiva
or gos no big dolphin skin uh it feels
like something I've never felt before
it's angel hair oh yeah yeah yeah it's
like sealed testicle that too it's very
confusing I'll leave it up thanks to
these videos people at playlist live
little kids was like hey can I touch
your hand thanks a lot guys alright so
this story is about a an X Chipotle
general manager who's a woman Janette
so she Janet I shouldn't it Jannetty to
cheese I think it's Jean je a.m. et te
yeah
okay got it alright well I'm glad we got
that we spoke to Paul a manager while
we're at it Jesus Christ on the game I
went for it well Nikki wants to
visualize visualize the words I can't
spell in my head I gotta write it as I
Sally if it said where they live Miller
with anyway Janet Jerry the one that
wanted to push with a [ __ ] to pull
the story and you pull the outfit I
needed to know I got thrown by Jeannette
alright so she worked and she was a
general manager for Chipotle across from
Fresno State campus but in January 2015
she was fired accused of stealing six
hundred and twenty six dollars in cash
from the safe well come on that's it I
know they're all whining about six
hundred bucks if you had six an orange
torn from your business you'd be pretty
good yeah that much support Leigh
like a multi-million billion dollar
business yeah but that billion our
business for some reason got a charge to
off for case so so we know they're
hurting somewhere I think it's more than
two bucks for K so it's two bucks for
guacamole tastes always do you know what
to do yeah yeah is it it's subtle this a
little bit yeah and it sucks one is not
$2.00 yeah these guys are out of their
minds yes the Jeanette had been with the
company for 14 years she was loyal she
she's stuck with the company for all
that time I didn't know what you pull it
been around that long we used to be
owned by McDonald's in my mind is still
a new thing
we're the Omaha dogs I thought they
wouldn't be bottom and then they sold
yeah exactly so apparently she put in
like a workers comp thing cuz she's got
carpal tunnel but she was still working
scooping from all the [ __ ] tortilla
for the GM Bros she worked her way up
well whatever [ __ ] carpal tunnel come
from work they just say this from word
Tiffany said don't be investigating I'm
not investigating already I jumped on I
just need to know her name again
I'm bigger for jokes thank you my next
one was gonna be jacking off and I was
like oh but it's a lady she's chillin
often carpal tunnel yeah this one
you give it a flick of the wrist okay
man
I think she's going through files yeah
and your wrist like that like parts dude
that's how you finger a woman no don't
the bummer
yeah well they love this not a good time
yeah feel for me to happily marry men
like I don't like fingers okay this is
correct no this is correct you go in
this story when you want extra power you
do you do now this you put Joe
[Laughter]
you get to to back up no one want extra
extra power you grab your own elbow yeah
strict no hands roll down there why
she's boring huh cuz of that did you
just see this [ __ ]
she's born it feels like you got a dead
salmon on your vagina you know why cuz
she doesn't want to come that hard
that's why it was too good to sensitive
my hands only Oh interesting
you don't want to just teach up no it's
cuz I'm too good I got spirit fingers do
it anymore mother but I don't say no
hands I say hey can you just use her
dick no just let's just use your dick
now alright sorry so uh what was I
saying she ended up doing a workers comp
thing and so she's saying that she was
wrongly fired because they said that
there was video video proof of her
stealing the cash that supposedly she
was Fanning the cash in front of her and
that she was looking behind her but then
her lawyer saying that's stupid doesn't
make sense why would she even do that if
she knows the cameras right over the
safe and then Chipotle said that they
all right cuz for $600 to find yourself
stupid yes event apolog said that they
somehow like lost that footage or they
don't have that footage anymore they
recorded over it the point is they don't
have it and so they can't show her that
footage and so she ended up suing for
wrongful wrongful termination Chipotle
offered her only a thousand dollars to
settle of the civil complaint but then
that's when her lawyer was asking for
ten mil and then what I found out came
mil turned into eight no a thousand turn
oh yeah it's like from 1010 mil you
didn't do it landed like 95
you know it's crazy six mil was just for
emotional distress whoa
six million can I get that for my exes
can I sue my ex's as I went through a
lot of emotional distress the part I
don't get when they have all these
lawsuits where there's this giant
inflated number for things that you
never even had but if they were like
okay I'll sue for three years worth of
work as general manager pay or whatever
it's like that's what you had but
they're suing for things like you've
never even had eight or ten million in
your life how can you sue for things
that you lost that you never everything
is made-up numbers it's all [ __ ] and
then people calling people on [ __ ]
and adding more [ __ ] then it's like
what number did we come up with after
all the [ __ ] yeah I don't get I
don't get the whole awesome game this
lady was accused of stealing oh yeah
from a safe in a wrongful II and they
don't they don't have footage never have
no evidence I get it you goddamn right
you should get eight million dollars
she's traumatized for the rest of her I
think her reputations damaged forever
every time you google her name she will
be busted as a as a thief or whatever
that's valid but if said that six
million was for emotional damages not
for a defamation of character well I'm
saying she sure they can do is give her
Employee of the Year higher back up
write another article covers all that
defamation zero money listen there are
all kinds of cases I think that what you
guys are doing is copy pasting your
feelings about all these lawsuits about
everybody's suing everything right but
this lady was like wrongfully accused
man I agree by the wrongfully accused
and I'm sad for life and I should get
six million to get a lawyer okay I think
this is like how much is it gonna cost
to make your sorrows go away six million
for emotional damage which is crazy
that's not yeah but six when it's true
those six million would make mine go
away if I got fired and people were like
hey you [ __ ] thief I'm not a thief
goddamn it and then you can pay for an
advertising campaign like Joe is not a
thief yeah and six million dollars okay
well I feel better now I can already
hear the lawyer like talking to her like
all right how bad do you feel like what
amount of money would make you well
have like like give me give me a number
how much money would make you feel huh
maybe like five thousand oh no no you
got a valley yourself a little bit more
how about like 10 million would that
make you feel good oh yeah
see we could really women when she gets
eight million she's like but I don't
feel that good I was gonna feel gonna
ten mil yeah you know what's everyone's
burrito now cost a dollar extra they
gotta pay for that [ __ ] now that's where
the [ __ ] case is two dollars well you
know what the queso isn't worth [ __ ]
ten dollars brother that shit's not good
it's $10 you know what I'm saying it's
not even it's not worth any money
because businesses it's the other
customers are in the pain for it
that's very true well suing suing is a
business some people are out there
predator only yeah that's the only way
they make money set like same with law
firms like they only [ __ ] that's how I
got sued people that was like why did
you get sued well I can't talk about cuz
I signed an NDA but to because the
person I sued me has a business out of
suing people like that's what he did
that's all they do
yeah Danny's good at his job then and he
pays to sue but it does say we're
leaving he know a soup or people like I
was on unemployment like I didn't even
have money poor people always pay yep
but they don't have the protection
that's right we settled he didn't even
get nothing he didn't win mmm but but I
paid him but he settled on like this I'm
gonna give you a donut and a [ __ ]
punch to the nose
[Music]
[Music]